in the expanded dune universe by Brian
Herbert and Kevin J Anderson woth was
the tactic leader of the clay laksa
ruling council during the return of the
honored MA trace the many Jesuit and
fish speaker offshoots that returned out
of the scattering 1,500 years after the
death of the worm God Emperor he allied
with the bin and Jesuit when his own
power and the flail axes civilization
was threatened by the morays woth was
led to believe by The Sisterhood that
they were true believers of the Zen
Sunni faith eventually the trial acts
who were almost entirely destroyed by
the owner of ma trace decades later a
gola of wofe will go on to create the
giant sea worms of the planet Buzzle
this gola was awakened imperfectly by
the honored mantra leader he'll occur in
its lilac sioux city known as banda long
after an attack by the new sisterhood
which was created by former honored
montre turned many jesuit marbella after
the death of the many Jesuit Reverend
mother Dario trade the goal of wofe
manages to escape with the help of the
guild navigator Edric for his help while
promises to create a new species of sand
worm their genetic alteration for the
guild to use
laughs eventually succeeded in producing
sandworms which did not grow vulnerable
to water as they mature beyond the phase
of the sand trout the spacing guild
commanded that wofe released some of the
young worms into the oceans of the
planet Buzzle home to the extremely
valuable su stones precious gems which
were found in the Seas of the planet
which were produced by the giant muscle
light creatures known as chala stirs the
sea worms quickly thrived on the planet
Buzzle and grow enlarged and strong
these extremely vicious and territorial
creatures eventually dominate the
planets entire ecosystem killing many
callisters and wreaking havoc on the SU
stone harvesting process by attacking
the Fibby 'it's the genetically modified
race of humanoid fish creatures
responsible for harvesting the SU stones
finally a worm is captured and harvested
from the sea inside its body lies an
organ which produces what is known as
ultra spice a concentrated version of
spice melange wofe delivers two spice to
the guild navigator edrick but it is
stolen and delivered to the synchrony
the capital of the thinking machine
Empire eventually omnious the ruler of
the thinking machines forces to golas of
Paul Atreides to fight to the death
the winner would receive the ultra spice
one is almost killed and the other is
declared winner upon ingestion of the
ultra spice the Golda's prescient powers
are increased to superhuman levels he
however realizes that this is too much
and goes into a type of overdose falling
into an irreversible coma he dies of
thirst and starvation this is the only
time Ultra spice is mentioned to be
consumed in the extended dune universe